[Music]
the average person
lives 27 375 days
that's all we get if we're lucky we just
wanted to come over and say hi
i am usually very witty and charming
bring it all right
did you pick it up it's better worse
than how about this
this is a horrible idea for a date oh so
this is a date no
[Music]
move in with me i will kick you out if
you suck to live with it
jen your man i know right i would serve
this in my restaurant
chop chop chef all right
i didn't know how much i could love
actually love until i met you
i've never wanted anything more than for
you to be my wife
this is all i want on my wedding day
[Music]
sir
hey if we get bad news we should get a
dog don't say that
we're getting good news
he's ours they found cancer
and it spread we don't have much time
left
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe we skip all of it the wedding just
feels like a lot right now
we knew that this was going to be hard i
am in this with you
i can't do this to you you don't get to
choose when i tap out
do i get to choose not alone not anymore
[Music]
this is going to be the happiest day of
our lives
thank you for showing me what living is
what homeless
you make me feel like i could do
anything well he can do anything
someone on five chances i don't see next
year four out of five you do
[Music]
every morning i wake up and i choose you
i choose us
[Music]
you